yeah chin we're good to go yeah we're a
little fire dots a little somber somber
somber day city's on fire that's how it
is and just want to say that's what's a
bright cause good night I wrote I texted
Will Sasso I go [ __ ] racist
he goes hey [ __ ] you I go yeah I know
you started this whole thing and I don't
that the fighting of the most people
feel is like I think overall this is
positive in a long way because because
the protests are just as many white
people black people there everybody's
like hey color hey this slow torture of
a man in broad daylight no I don't give
a [ __ ] and a guy keep seeing these memes
about like he did this you know back
that doesn't I don't care about [ __ ]
you're talking about the slow torture of
a man in broad daylight and that's it
and and the death the optimality in the
hands that all the time this we just
happening at counting yeah but the
problem is is these looters who are the
1% of the protesters that are damaging
every city they can find yeah do all
this stuff that the hair white I'm sorry
no they're not I don't like it no it's
not all just right and auntie for that's
not fair that's true you give an auntie
for too much credit yeah a lot of those
it's the black looters well a lot of
those people are people who are looting
who you know 40 million people are
unemployed yeah whoo and then you stick
for the mayor the mayor of Atlanta said
you know and and killer Mike said do you
want to make a difference keep don't
burn your own house down sign up a
register go to the census so they know
who you are and where you are yeah
that's the long game you want action now
yes people actually know the other thing
is is uh you know the looters are you
know it's it's 99% of the media coverage
and I think media is the enemy of the
state you look at the the coverage that
they're posting you know there's been
way more positive and friendly
harpus on peaceful protest and there's
been looters but these looters the 1%
are painting the narrative so everyone
thinks this is the you know the world's
on fire yeah the other thing is there
other positive the other positive is
that policing in 2015 they were like
weed they had a was still a problem but
they had a major problem I think
something like a hundred to unarmed
black men were killed and we know the
stories and some of the store
we don't know about and in 2019 it was
nine it's been a better there's been a
dramatic decrease so it is like because
they diversified police forces there are
a lot more black cops and so so it there
has been progress made so you shouldn't
feel that heavy hearted there's still
work to be done if there's progress for
sure I mean it does feel like that we've
never been more divided and I woke up
super bummed
and I tell podcasts sucked yeah I was
depressed I fell like cry big old all
right I'll do that
that was cried at the end of my set my
final set Saturday should have I I swear
to God I was trying not that I was
trying not to cry yeah well there was
that when I was in the airport there's a
little black girl so [ __ ] cute
playing soccer with her dad and I was
just sitting there and I was missing my
kid she came towards me who doesn't want
to play mm-hmm I started tearing up
under the Dow's like you know like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with Dube is just like
I know everything going on she kicked
this little ball must want to play she's
like three I'm like [ __ ] do I ever
let's do it and then I scored seven
goals dude you can't do that you get
better yes you can't talk trash to my
soccer man you can't take it that white
girl white pilot you're the problem and
you kick the ball in her face yes and
then you started it you started to riot
mmm yeah and the the airport come fire
that's besides the point
um yeah man Houston was great though ah
[ __ ] we had such a blast in Houston yeah
well you know you have you have a cop
problem most of the cops in the world
are most of the cops fantastic the tough
strum in the world they're very hard job
they do a great job you are always gonna
have I'm sorry say you're always gonna
have [ __ ] in every business and
you're gonna have murderers in every
business they're gonna [ __ ] things up
for the flow did you post our video
finally yeah I did yeah
[Applause]
back to normal it was so cool I felt I
had energy all weekend like I've never
had I just was like well we went after
that we went to this place called fab
Ian's and we did some [ __ ] dancing
well I did I'm a salsa dancer
I spoke to go and watch well leave it
leave it to Latin you only have one look
leave it till out and people neuropathy
in advance leave it leave it to Latin
people who are like everything is
burning and they're just like the party
goes on well about it was packed I was
just I felt like I was everything was
normal again
I miss Chris he was interested in
Chicago on Friday when the protest start
so I would leave I like to get to the
venue early Brian let's go a little
later you know Brian's a vet I feed
there early cover my fees and queues and
whatever Fabian's there it is Latin
flavors so we're getting ready to go and
I hear all I see a hotline probably 20
cop cars fly past this and I heard the
[ __ ] is going on I'm mama social media
that much anymore and like what is going
on I see all this stuff happening and I
looked down the street and it's the
protesters and I see three tanks I look
into our tanks tanks no wonder you text
me I was taking a nap I was scared I
went B we gotta get out pretty well
Brendan woke me up I'm napping I'm like
you know it's like I'm supposed to be
what was it like 7:00 supposed to be it
starts at 7:30 but I'm taking my long
little nappy-poo
and you were like we got to get up yeah
yeah other because I talked to when the
cops go what's going on he's protest
like oh [ __ ]
you just don't even start barricading
everywhere around here so I know damn
out of shorts mes you better get going
using your not gonna be able to get back
in for a while Pam so that's one like
dude we gotta get the [ __ ] out and we
should just stay in a hotel no I packed
my survival back you do i pad my flares
I told JJ my canteen jegos what money do
about my contacts
we'll go to CVS and get you the juice to
put him in dude but I'm gonna [ __ ]
come back here like zombie land and
figure it out yeah there's this you know
it's a vulnerable feeling Venice man I
just heard cuz I live right near that
fire a house in Venice and I know they
just kept the engines just kept coming
out oh I think the restaurant the fire
now you see those trucks come through
and you're just like damn well yeah
there's a curfew today in Santa Monica
supposed to be up one
yet in for for working people yeah no
fun is for businesses and for for
everybody else so got you by the way I
was I was not a fan of the shutdown I'm
a fan of curfews when when shits out of
complete because you know these antiva
and these other rioters and looters what
they do in their their camouflaging
themselves within the peaceful protest
I'm hijacking regular people so you
can't it's harder to figure out what's
going on well this was her fee though no
one's out you can kind of single them
out this black woman was like watching
these two white kids maybe an Tifa and
they're like they were spray paint black
lives matter on this storefront and she
was like hey hey we're not here to cause
vandalism I'm here to [ __ ] protest
you guys are hijacking this and she said
this isn't us they're gonna blame us it
was pretty [ __ ] I was like that but
again that's why you can't let these
rights paint the narrative of what's
going on and and mask what really you
know is the problem the judicial system
and black people and all that yes it's a
real problem
so somebody Martin Luther King said
riding is a reaction it is not a
response and and he said Martin Luther
King I was very I'll find the quote but
it was really interesting about how it
when you riot and you destroy an
inherent is that in that is defeat and
it's not something that you're gonna
change well do you see our boy Eddie
Bravo's Jim yeah man you wanna ruin your
day yeah
our good friend Eddie Jim destroyed set
on fire yeah unusable I mean there's
insurance and stuff and we'll start
GoFundMe for him but still I'll tell you
what it's a lot you know when you see
the riots in Chicago and New York you
know I said I Love New York I love
Chicago but when it's not in your
hometown or not places you know you got
god that's terrible but you kind of move
on when you're watching the news right
well hold that's that's Main Street well
we're right by the well that I go to I
eat lunch there
oh well that's run oh but box and burn
well that's wrong but though that's
wrong you're like holy [ __ ] yeah it's
very it hits home like anything else but
but at least we got to do what we do and
make people laugh
yeah how about i-94 said let's take you
to the neighborhoods cuz they got kicked
off social media it's like oh geez well
here's what's in see me all my all my
very anti-gun liberal friends I've had
three phone calls not all but three
phone calls and they're all like
do you have where can I get guns and do
you have a gun and can I call you and
I'm like very [ __ ] up do because I got
home yesterday and I saw everything
going on and I turn on the news to watch
you know Santa Monica I'm firing them
doing their [ __ ] thing and I didn't
think Tigers pay attention I was playing
with his toys and then he's tried wants
to go to bed and he's all scared like
he's scared dude he starts talking about
you know the rise you know how they're
gonna come here my god [ __ ] then he
can't sleep my kids too and then he goes
pop I've been shaking my bed all night
you come on get in bed oh oh there's a
long night dude I [ __ ] up I didn't
think you spaying attention they pay
attention they pay attention my kids
same way yeah my kids same way yeah so
hopefully you know my father wants a cop
man and well a thief has been labeled a
terrorist organization always going to
be and what that means which people are
like oh the state is distract away from
what to do it will say what you want my
own teachable what happened I don't mean
I rep you good now it's the same thing
that we did with the when we had a mafia
problem is when they make you know those
terrorist laws and people it's not that
big of you know it's a big deal because
if you're not all the way in on antifa
and you get caught and you're part of
that go into prison for 40 years are you
looking at you're looking at federal
crimes and that's when they say that's
how they got the the mob to snitch
because they went well well you know you
can get 40 years now and you get caught
up in the RICO Act as well yeah that's a
nightmare if you're caught with with
people who are an anti fight you can be
cured I know I always kind of been on
Trump's nuts a little bit I like the it
to Politico beelines nuts a little bit
during Corona which I've appreciate him
for and open up the state and stuff like
that forget crimes you know who he's a
[ __ ] again I'll lick your face [ __ ] mask
but in with this all this going on
I would like my present come out and
take some leadership and speak on this
oh why because he came out and said when
the looting starts the shooting starts
which was what which is an original
which is what the chief of police in
1968 said in Miami when people were
protesting civil rights and he said if
they want to see police brutality they
they haven't seen anything yet that was
a racist police chief white police chief
in Miami and the problem is when you're
president in 2020 [ __ ] quotes that
you
using your using Rayo my people about
losing language from 1968 that a racist
police chief used think of a [ __ ]
better quote dude also original he said
at first it wasn't bad he goes there did
these looters are dis honoring the
memory of but George Floyd I won't let
that happen
can you stop there can you not say you
know and did you have to tag it with
when the looting starts the shooting
starts what everybody like killer Mike
and everybody who's a [ __ ] black
leader knows exactly what that means you
can't do that you're the Tim Walz told
me that the military is with him all the
way any difficulty in we will assume
control but when the looting starts the
shooting starts taken from what what's
his name Walter Harold what's up [ __ ]
there were chief of police in 19 seasons
away though what I can't say that you
cannot say I want my yeah I want I want
the leader of the free world to come out
and at least try to come up with an
eloquent way to yeah but Bobby he's a
lawn or president meaning look al
Sharpton was very very clear on this al
Sharpton said you guys have to be
careful not to destroy your
neighborhoods because what happens is
you will if it's a self-defeating
prophecy in the six in where after
Martin Luther King was was assassinated
there were there was looting and rioting
and and Al Sharpton was 13 years old and
and what happened was people got scared
and they voted in a long order president
and that was President Nixon you have to
be careful because sometimes when you
are protesting and destroying things
people get scared they want order and
you are going to it's a self-defeating
prophecy so again this is not lost on
the mass majority of especially black
protesters who are protesting peacefully
so you know it's it's it's hard man it's
funny this is an emotional catharsis for
a lot of people it's [ __ ] hard it's
just hard man you know let's move on
dude yeah right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue Oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[ __ ] business